all right now there were major
developments surrounding the Biden
family Syndicate and new details with
Congressman Comer now a whistleblower is
telling Congress that the FBI and the
doj are in possession of a document
detailing an alleged criminal scheme
involving then Vice President Joe Biden
taking money from foreign Nationals in
exchange for policy decisions in other
words that would be bribery now house
oversight committee chairman James Comer
has now issued a subpoena for that
document based on what he and Senator
grafley are calling a quote legally
protected and highly credible
whistleblower disclosure now Once Upon a
Time the media Democrats the mob they
they loved and revered whistleblowers
even hearsay whistleblowers anyway in
fact the first impeachment hoax against
President Trump that was based on an
anonymous whistleblower who never ever
even testified but now liberal hacks
like Adam Schiff John King at fake news
CNN they're not interested in serious
claims of government corruption take a
look at this
a stunning allegation Joe Biden taking
foreign money to shape U.S policy also
stunning I would argue more stunning the
Republicans making this claim admit they
have no evidence just an unverified tip
I wouldn't give much stock to this but
I'm not surprised they push out these
unsubstantiated allegations they've been
doing it for some time do you think the
American people deserve to hear from
this person and the FBI should answer
these questions
at this point is just the most rampant
speculation we don't even know if there
is such a document or what the document
pertains to all we have is someone's
representation and it doesn't even sound
like he knows what it pertains to now
you got to remember this is the same
cast of characters breathlessly day
after day night after night they're the
ones that push the Russia hoax for three
years no evidence no facts no truth just
uh hope and a dream just a reminder take
a look the question has shifted from
whether the president is working with
the Russians to what evidence exists
that the president is not we're working
with the Russians because we are looking
at the possibility that the president of
the United States and those around him
during an election campaign colluded
with a hostile foreign power to
undermine the basis of our democracy
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there it sees for him
we'll call it hurricane Vladimir if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion This Cloud about collusion
with Russia will hang over him no matter
where he stands and certainly say with
confidence that there is significant
evidence of collusion between the
campaign and Russia
ult lies Democrats the media mob they
don't care about truth or Justice or
accountability or transparency they just
want to win elections at all costs
consolidate power against the American
people but now more than ever checks and
balances are critically vitally
important Joe Biden is a corrupt
dishonest greedy career politician who
is not to be trusted with the very
latest is house oversight committee
chairman James Comer is with us sir how
are you
I'm well thanks all right let me go to
the letter that that you and Chuck
rashley uh wrote to Mayor Garland the AG
and you're very clear on what you say
here that you have a legally protected
highly credit uh credible whistleblower
and that it came to your attention and
grassley's attention that the doj the
FBI possess an unclassified form in
fd-1023 form that describes quote an
alleged criminal scheme involving then
Vice President Biden and a foreign
National relating to the exchange of
money for policy decisions what can you
tell us uh Congressman Comer
well Senator Grassley and I both
reviewed that disclosure we find it very
credible we're very concerned we have a
lot of questions as to whether or not
the FBI even looked into this we know
from your previous reporting that you've
already stated on the show that they
turned a blind eye to anything
pertaining to Joe Biden and they just
assumed the worst when they look into
anything that pertains to former
president Trump so we're very concerned
about this and I'll tell you why Sean
because as you know I possess bank
records from the Biden family now and
there's a consistent pattern of the
bidens using llc's to receive payments
from our adversaries around the world
including the Chinese Communist party
and many other countries that go into
various llc's and then they transfer
them around in a type of money
laundering scheme and then transfer the
money back to different Biden family
members we've identified nine Biden
family members that have received these
type of payments from adversarial
countries around the world now the
question is what are they doing to
receive these payments then we get this
very credible whistleblower come forward
and we have again reviewed this specific
disclosure so now we're requesting that
disclosure from the FBI and we want to
know exactly what they've done to verify
whether or not this this allegation is
true Congressman you said twice you
viewed this disclosure I want to ask you
about that have you seen this this
document this evidence that the FBI and
the doj have are you sure they have not
destroyed it
I think it would be very difficult to
destroy it's my understanding that it is
submitted within their database and it's
very difficult to take that out and
destroy it because
yeah well we've uh you know we we're
seeing it all with respect to the FBI
unfortunately but we're very confident
that this does exist uh we're very
confident in The Whistleblower and look
this fits a pattern of behavior that the
bidens have done because we've we've
already identified millions of dollars
into nine different Biden family members
and we don't have any idea what they did
to receive that money there are no
businesses that's what the Biden
attorneys and their friends in the media
have said well these were legitimate
investments into different Biden
business interests there are no business
interest Sean the business was the
bidens creating different llc's trying
to hide who the source of the transfer
was and then deceive the IRS and then
goes back into the Biden's back pockets
so what did they do to receive this
money and again we take our
whistleblowers very seriously as you
know there have been two very credible
whistle doors come forward in the last
two weeks we're doing everything we can
to protect these whistleblowers and to
try to encourage more whistleblowers to
come forward but we have credible
evidence and we want to know exactly
okay let me ask you this I did to verify
this you talk about a foreign National
do you know what country this foreign
National is from A and B you talk about
the exchange of money for policy
decisions do you know how much money and
do you know what the policy decisions
were
I know the country and I know the policy
decision but I'm not at Liberty to say
right now again
you'll be the first to know to be honest
Congressman you're talking about a vice
president being bribed and he's now the
president of the of the this country you
know a balloon flies however our country
and nothing happens uh a drone is taken
out of the sky and nothing happens uh is
it because uh the president is
compromised I worry about that Am I
Wrong to worry about that
no you're exactly right that's why we're
investigating Joe Biden the media wants
to talk about Hunter Biden look we've
already disclosed that there are nine
Biden family members it isn't just about
the president's son it isn't just about
the president's brother it's about the
president's entire family but we'll be
real
wait does anyone believe that they're
getting this money just as coincidence I
mean there are countless transactions
from from many countries countries that
no one else would ever do business with
even some of the biggest companies in
America that are that have a huge
International footprint don't even do
business in some of these countries what
are they doing to receive this money
this fits a pattern with everything that
our whistleblower are very credible
whistleblower has alleged that Joe Biden
did when he was vice president that's
why we want to know what the FBI has
done to verify this claim we know they
have the claim we want to know what
they've done to verify the please do not
let them destroy the evidence
chairman Comer thank you we appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else